by the governor as a result of the
kroger 19 pandemic
accords with the governor's emergency
rule number 12 pursuant to executive
order
2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee in select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during the
meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform the public
has access to contemporaries listed and
if necessary
participate in the meeting by zoom
platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general
website
the notice of this meeting complies with
house rules and rsa 91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting
shall call 271-3600
or email hcs at leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff
that are on the meeting assisting us
brad grievan who's the committee
researcher
[Music]
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by a roll call vote
let's start the meeting by a roll call
attendance with each member
states their presence please also state
whether there's anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required
this time the clerk will not call the
role
by sherman welch yeah
representative burke
yes representative hopper
representative greene representative
wallace
representative testerman yeah
representative true
representative pratt
representative marston
the clerk is present representative
harry gathright
i am present i am in this room alone
and i can hear everyone representative
pantalakis
i'm here hello
representative sue newman
yes present in the room alone
representative boarding
president in the room alone
representative muse
i'm here and alone in my office
representative
ray newman i'm here and my wife is in
her office
representative bolden
um i'm home uh president with family
representative conley i am present my
wife and kids are in the house they're
not in the same room
although they'll probably come through
from time to time
representative klein knight i'm alone in
the room
i'm present and family member
may come in once in a while but alone
for now
representative bradley i'm here and
alone
chairman abbas the chair's president
mr chairman everybody is present
[Music]
this time the chair i recognize
representative martin's leaders
representative
yes sir my understanding was that you
were in the
preparation of an uh a potential
amendment for senate bill 122.
that's correct i have had it distributed
by
the staff person brad
bradley is that one of that
senate bill i don't know i got a copy of
the bill but i don't have a copy of the
motherboard
is the amendment in the room i don't
think so no
no all right no amendments present
all right
at least with senate bill 34.
this time that you're going to open the
executive session on senate bill
34.
zayn would wish to make a motion before
why once now
for a bill
question for uh the chair
you recognize for a question uh thank
you
um chairman abbas
are we allowed to discuss this bill
before we make a motion
if you wish to make a comment you can be
recognized you were recognized from the
department of senate
[Music]
representative i'm recognizing
representative though
oh no thank you i was um just wondering
if we could have a discussion before we
make a motion
it was recognized to make a motion so
anyone we should discuss any any parts
of the bill
deals with uh synthetic drugs and
the overwhelming majority of synthetic
drugs trying to stand up manufactured in
china and the biggest problem you have
with the synthetic drug
as opposed to a natural one think of
this
cocaine is always cocaine and it
combines it's
cut with different substances or
products and things are added to it
but ultimately the main ingredient is
always the main ingredient
with synthetic drugs it's more of a
chemical situation so the problem is
you can define a synthetic drug but
what would happen is
if you change some minor ingredients
it's no longer a fixed definition or
it's hard to prove if it's the
definition
of the synthetic drug my understanding
the intent of senate bill 34
is to really tighten up the definition
of synthetic drugs
which would make it easier to enforce
those laws
because the burden of proof on the state
is very difficult if
you add salt or whatever you you add
some some parts to it
and change the whole ingredient so it
would make it easier to improve
so that's really the intent of the bill
did i i know it obviously passed in the
senate it's a senate bill i think it
passed 23 to
201 from what i expect
and i'm not allowed to make a motion but
if i was i would probably
i would i'm inclined to support it
representative rhodes you recognized
thank you mr chairman
i'll make a motion ought to pass for
house bill 34
second do you mean senator 34
that is exactly what i mean
you wished a second yeah
i have one question i hate to be a pain
it's
representing fine night you were
recognized for a question
thank you um i know one of our questions
uh was would this affect the private
sale
for anyone trying to protect like their
garden or their farm or anything like i
know that was discussed can
does anybody have any more information
on that this
as i understood it this bill wouldn't
change the right
for a consumer to to purchase synthetic
urine correct
my understanding it's just me
that under the current law it is illegal
to manufacture
distribute or in any way
use synthetic urine uh my understanding
the senate bill could pass although it
repeals that section
it would remain it would all continue to
be
illegal to manufacture possess or
otherwise use
synthetic urine and that is that has
been a problem
in the past it's not as widely talked
about but is
it's often used to manipulate drug tests
or try to
pass a drug test so there is a market
for it
representative hopper you're recognized
for a question thank you mr chairman
i'm not all that opposed to uh the first
part of this
uh bill about the uh trying to uh
clarify what
synthetic drugs are but i am uh
adamantly opposed to lumping bills
together
by the senate um i think it denies
people what is one of the hallmarks of
the new
legislature is access the ability for
anybody
to look at a bill and and comment or
send a letter to the legislator
by lumping bills together there are
bills that are going uh being
passed or failed under the wire that the
public has no awareness of
because it was part of an ominous uh
bill in the senate
so i i'm going to vote against this uh
on principle
i think represent hopper is is senate
bill 34
actually an ominous bill it has two
separate fields but
is it an ominous name
so it's not anonymous
representative you were recognized thank
you mr chairman i
don't know if somebody can answer this
but
i believe hunters use
synthetic urine
[Music]
for hunting purposes so what will this
do well
for you what you're talking about is not
human
synthetic hearing so you i think what
you want to do is look at the definition
of synthetic urine i think it's listen
right now
any using any substance or any product
if you go to any lighting store
right they have they sell products and
if you were to take that product
you would clean out your system to the
point that you would at least not test
positive
for any controlled substance all right
now if you go to the store and
at the vitamin store or whatever and you
say i need to
buy this because i need to pass a drug
test
that's against the law they actually are
not allowed to sell you the
material anymore even though it's legal
for the next person how do you buy it
because they're not buying for that
purpose
if the price if the merchant knows what
you're going to use it for the
manipulate drug test it makes it illegal
so it's i mean for the people most
people
sadly most people know how to get around
that by not saying that whether
or not
i don't believe god using synthetic
journal purposes
people buy this bill and to the extent
that it would it's already illegal
on the parallel it's simply striking the
section and replacing it
which seems counterproductive but that's
how it goes right
representative wallace um
we all know this is all based upon
intent what's the intent of the
legislator
of the legislature what's the intent of
the actor and what are we doing
in this section about the synthetic
but if we say synthetic human urine
that will protect the hunters i can
believe because that gives you synthetic
gear urine
and things like that uh to hide the
human scent so you're more
you look for a chapter i can imagine
there's a definition section
of chapter well it's bringing a new one
but
i dig into the existing wall it should
be a definition section
they repealed these actions
yes
i don't have my book
while everyone's looking into them i can
imagine a lot of us have some
friends that are very knowledgeable with
fishing game laws
and someone perhaps we consider reaching
out
[Music]
what's up
can i ask um
just one moment if you go to lines 28
to 30 on
page
[Music]
h2 i think it actually requires a heat
from a person
so i think that would be human urine
that's what i was suggesting was yeah if
you use the
synthetic urine i guess if you're using
it for hunting purposes what it means it
would be a lawful use
similar to that of the stuff you buy the
vitamin shop you know you can
use it to cleanse your system there's a
lot of health benefits of cleansing your
system
probably not doing it to manipulate drug
or alcohol screening it's legal
some people walk in the store and they
can't find it that's how they ask to
find it
hence they can't get the sale same thing
here
i suppose if you're buying a synthetic
urine
legally it would uh be crime if you tell
the person
yeah you have to use the best drugs
that's my that's my reading boyle's not
defined
[Music]
if it passes so representative penalties
you recognize her question
yes thank you mr chairman i just wanted
to state
that i believe that if the hunters
would be affected by this they would
have come out of force
amen
[Music]
second website is an excellent point
representative klein knight you'll
recognize her great question
thank you chairman i think that um it's
good to question these bills because
we've seen a lot of poorly written
things come from the senate recently
so um you know asking the right
questions
it it can be better for our people
just try lightly when we're speaking
about the other body
okay thank you no need to throw comments
like that
great okay so um i disagree with what
representative pandalaka said then i'll
just leave it at that
the fact that there are hunters the fact
that there are gardeners
there's a lot of people that use this we
didn't get any data that says how many
people
are using uh fake urine illegally
um i also want to know the sign in
numbers if representative muse can give
that to us
well well representative is looking for
that i will tell you that using
synthetic urine
today is also a crime so it's not like
we're creating
a new crime it's not something that's
legal today that becomes legal tomorrow
so i i i certainly don't think we should
if we don't pass this bill
we ipl centerfield 34 the
market for synthetic urine will still be
just as illegal today as it is
tomorrow are you talking about synthetic
human urine or synthetic animal urine
because that's not clear in this
and that's what people use legally well
what i explained was
if you look on page two right i provide
line numbers it explains
when this would be invoked
h2 lines 28 to 30 because if you're
using it
it has to do when you're using it to a
human's using synthetic urine to
be a drug test so if you're selling
someone synthetic urine in the
with the knowing that they're going to
use it to manipulate the results of a
drug test
that is a crime if you're married i want
to know if it's already legal to
manipulate
a drug test i think this is unnecessary
well
i may agree with you that but what this
bill did was strike the existing section
and basically cut and paste and re-put
the
same section back in the wall i didn't
ask the senate why they chose to do that
but it seemed to be rather circular but
i could imagine it's
just that's sometimes easier to say
if you amend or a whole section
sometimes it's easier just to have
have the whole thing redone rather than
remodel
they don't know doesn't mean they don't
have anything in common from the last
option
and just the members participating at
home
just a reminder once the matter is put
to questions
as soon as i say the matter will now be
put to question
if you are not in your seat you will not
be permitted to vote
if you are participating remotely uh if
your camera is not on
when the matter is put to question you
will be ruled by the chair to not be in
your seat
uh so i do recommend uh if possible that
people uh
the members participating remotely try
to keep their cameras on
i would try and remind you to remind
everyone but if i don't it's what it is
sign ins on sb 34 um there were six
people who signed in
in support and two people who signed in
in opposition
seeing no further hands raised the
matter will now be put
right in time represent them seeing no
further hands raise the matter will now
be put to question
[Music]
if you're in favor of the most nevada
pass please say yay
if you are opposed please say nay the
clerk will not call the roll
vice chairman welch yes
representative bert no
representative hopper no
representative green no
representative wallace no
representative testerman yeah
representative true no
representative pratt yes
representative marston
no the clerk votes yes
representative harriet gathering yes
representative pantawakis
yes representative sue newman
yes representative borden a
yes representative muse
yes representative ray newman
yes representative bowden
no representative conley
yes representative klein knight
no representative bradley
yes chairman
cheer votes yes mr chairman the vote is
13 yay
eight nay
i bought 13 days in eight names the
motion of bought the pass
was passed representative rose will you
be preparing a majority report
yes i'm going to get minor reports
representative will you be preparing a
minority report not on this bill
you know by the end of the day and i
don't care if it goes on consent
this time we'll now close the executive
session on senate bill 34.
at this time now open the executive
session on
senate bill 40.
it is an amendment that was prepared
by
[Music]
and the chair will once this amendment's
passed around the chair will recognize
representative chesman making motions
about the past and offered
is graciously handing out the amendment
it's member number 2021-1357h
the members at home have a copy of that
yes
mr chairman can you tell me the
amendment number again please
yes it's 2021-1357
thank you
still kindly handing that out also there
was a similar house bill
that we passed that was hp 485
um although i did i did like that though
better
uh if that bill has been retained by the
center
so i i don't think we should let that
necessarily interfere what we want to do
but just to keep that in mind anyone
wants to look it up
but uh at this time the channel
recognizes representative testing to
make the most of ought to pass off the
web
i'd like to make a uh pass on senate
bill 40
uh with an amendment and is that going
to be seconded by anyone
a second of the purposes of discussion
that has been that has been segmented by
representative wells
of the uh representative you were
recognized to speak on the amendment
uh the amendment was it was one that my
uh chief of police asked me to
submit uh he agrees with the rest of the
bill
he just wants to make sure that if
they're walking around the car let's say
for example
and they happen to see something in the
back seat
that they can you know
conduct a search and so all he did was
add the word
solely in the uh phrase it says
cannot be fairly further detained solely
for refusing
because there's something new that's
that's different
so that's all this amendment does
and if i recall the testimony correctly
and because it's why
[Music]
this this concept whether it's a senator
hp 45 it's it's it's new
so there isn't really any any case or
guidance on
how to proceed often
when we have search and procedure law
it's all
been established over generations of
case law and
up and down the left this is really a
new
process so although the word adding the
word solely i thought
i didn't interpret it as a necessary
word it certainly does provide an extra
layer of clarification
and the idea from when i spoke with some
police officers the reason why they
support adding that language
is to avoid potential unnecessary
litigation down the line
by clarifying you know i found it to be
clear already
i don't find any problem overkill here
just to make sure it's
certainly what the intent of that
section is
so if you support the underlying bill i
don't see any
problem with the amendment it's not
changing the
intent of the bill it's really not
changing how the bill would operate it's
just literally
clarifying what it was initially
intended to do
representative news you're recognized
yes thank you we did hear during the um
uh during the public hearing from the
aclu and also from attorney cher
um and both objected to the addition of
the word
uh solely um uh
the testimony from uh attorney share was
that in his opinion
uh hb 40 is well well worded as it uh as
it stands
um and i think some of the concern was
that if you actually add the word
uh solely refusing to consent to the
search
uh itself would provide a reason to
detain the person
in and of itself so what it essentially
would do is change
the uh the meaning of the uh the meaning
of the statute and
uh and really it would affect the
purpose of the bill
representative testified to respond to
the jesus comment
yeah i i have a problem with bud
and the aclu continuing to victimize or
everybody and i do
appreciate the fact that they're
well versed in everything but i
just i just disagree with their
their opinions in some cases
and just to touch on that if you go to
the
underlying bill and you go to page
first page of the bill and we're a lot
this is line 12. in line
12 edgard says the operator cannot be
further detained
for refusing to consent to a search
this says the offer cannot be further
detained solely
for refusing to consent to research
so they're saying that i'm reading that
to
say that if by you refusing to be
consent
just like if you refuse to answer on
police officers questions that
in and of itself cannot be used to
establish probable cause or detain you
for any reason
now they're saying if you're this ain't
solely for refusing it's just
emphasizing if you're just
opposing or objecting to being searched
for that reason that reason is the
police cannot
detain it this to me it actually narrows
the scope
uh but at the same time this is how law
enforcement
they wanted to be as specific as
possible state and comply
this is not expanding what they can do
it's actually narrowing it
considering it's coming from police
officers uh
who actually put in this suggestion it
was refreshing to actually uh
have that but i i just hear it for
coming they want to do it right
so i i don't think this creates any
confusion i understand that
some people are objecting to it in their
testimony saying was a bad idea
i think if we could see any build if we
can clarify language we should do that
to make sure it's applied correctly
especially when it comes to what law
enforcement candy can't do
uh i i support the amendment i don't
again i don't think
i i think the bill i would support build
up the amendment but i don't see the
reason for objecting to that lane
representative harry jeffrey you're
recognized
yes i remember the testimony well and i
am not for that amendment
and i too felt that the solely does not
clarify
it's the word the verbiage that's on the
original bill
is clear it's very clear so i would not
be supporting
the amendment
representative i represent raining would
you recognize
thank you mr chair just i also agree
with
uh what the ranking member just said
i'm wondering about the word solely do
you need two things
to meet the fact that you can't be
further charged
i think solely depending on how you
define that word could make it more
confusing thank you mr chair
so there's it's somewhat of an objective
balancing test from when someone can and
can't be retained
i've detained and
what this is saying is you can't take
into consideration
if all you have is several factors but
if all you have is
the fact that the person is uh objecting
to the search
that fact may not be the only factor you
rely upon
you detain the person now
by saying the word solely it's saying
that you if you only have that
if you get rid of the word solely it
it's saying it can be part of other
stuff
or perhaps you can rely solely on just
the fact that personal objectives so
again
i don't think i i don't think it's
confusing at all and i'm
i think this this provides clarification
and if you heard the testimony this is
what
they the intended the bill was and i
think it was
great the law enforcement wants that
clarified so
that's just me i i don't understand why
why it would create
people by adding that i'm surprised
people object to it
i think the bill is fine without it as
well so it's not it's not
i would hope that people wouldn't vote
against the ought to pass with the
americans
representative klein knight you're
recognized thank you chair i would have
really liked to
see um police officers show up and
testify
that they wanted an amendment like this
and speak to all of us and not just one
representative so we could have
gotten a more clear understanding of the
intent
and i also again asked to be treated
the same as my colleagues across the
aisle i think that
saying i don't trust the um
organization that made a comment on this
and saying generalizing that they
all tend to victimize everybody is way
worse than the comment i made earlier so
i just want to point that out
when i say i don't trust a bill because
we've been getting a lot of bad
poorly written things and just cause you
[Music]
all right and if something comes from
there that's not written
the way we would have written it and we
put an amendment then
there's no need to offer criticism i and
i address that reason not to vote for it
represented
you are not recognized to speak at this
time if this continues and you know the
rules by now
i will ask i'm going to have to ask you
to be removed from the room well
you're not in the room but you know what
i mean so please
just let we are not talking over each
other
it does not it does not need to be
conducted that way we have a very long
day we have to do all the subcommittee
assignments today
we're going to go through the stuff
that's been incurred uh whether we want
to concur with it with the senate or if
you want to
disagree with that there's a lot of
things we have to do today and if you
just want to keep
yelling out of turn it's going to be a
very long day
and you know you know the rules of uh of
the house by now and i'm sure i've
explained to you enough times do you
understand if you can't just yell out a
term
all i'm saying is in any comments about
the other organizations
if i miss that i'm i'm i accept my
apology i'm not perfect
all right but we don't need to be doing
that it's not a healthy way to start the
day
so i would ask that we don't criticize
anyone
period whether it's an organization the
other body
and that's it all right that's my
decision i want to talk about any
further if you bring it up i'm going to
give you out of order because that's not
what you're recognized to do
if you want to provide critiques i'm
sure you'll do it on your twitter
account
you wish to speak the amendment i will
recognize you to speak to your amendment
by excluding the representative
testaments and then
representative ray newman you were
recognized
thank you mr chair um i agree with your
ruling previously about dissent and the
way
um and i think all should take into
consideration that we
not should not challenge motivation
either of other representatives or
of organizations um i just think that's
increase
i think that you're right uh sometimes
the emotions get to a high pitch in this
committee
and i guess that at my reading of when
the chair says
you are out of here or you're not that
the requirement for the
individual is to stop speaking until the
speaker is finished
and then if they have a comment with
that afterwards
that's the way i would consider to be
right
thank you thank you representative and
i'm clearly
holding the whole on every committee uh
and just to clarify i i understand that
there was a comment that if the
any this was an amendment that was
supported by some members of law
enforcement they should
come in they did i believe it was chief
goldstein who became
testified in support of this event in
uh during his testimony i don't and
that's
i don't have the right police officer
please correct the representative
testament
chief goldstein is the one who asked for
this amendment
he's on the list of attendees now you
can ask him
if he did it's up to you
do you do you remember was that
i i don't remember if you testify i just
remember
i just know that he's the one who asked
for this and that
if anybody has any questions about the
police department he's a very senior
you know police
[Music]
representative about boardnet you were
recognized
thank you mr chair i will say that
according to my notes uh
chief goldstein did support the
idea of adding slowly into this
bill however i cannot support
the edition thank you
thank you
[Music]
guess not seeing no further hands raised
the matter will now be no matter what
i'll be put the question
that's three of you won't have your
cameras on
so
declare for now call the role if you are
in support
of the of adopting did we have a
motion okay
representative tesla means emotion and
then you secondly all right
you want to make sure
see if you're in support of adopting
amendment number 2021-1357
please say yay if you are opposed please
say nay department i'll call the roll
vice chairman welch
representative bert yes
representative hopper yes
representative greene yes
representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true yeah
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes the clerk votes yes representative
harry gathered
oh representative pantalakis
yes representative sue newman
no representative boarding a
no representative muse
representative ray newman no
representative bolden
no representative conley
no representative klein knight
no representative bradley
no chairman
chair votes yes mr chairman
we had we had three members that did not
have their cameras on
the lever of the those three members as
i said
and i announced this rule beginning um
those votes should not be counted
because they're not considered in their
seat
representative you've raised the point
of order and that that was my point of
view mr chair that
there were people right in their seat
that everyone was logged in was going
i believe i believe the procedure is to
call the name
which they were called by the vote
should not be
recorded for those people who were not
in their seat
understood i i and i
i agree with that 100 and that that
would be how the chairman would rule
with them
so be challenged
may i ask a question of the chair
we're still let me let the clerk
announce the the results of the vote
and then you're you can ask
well recognize you ask a question
thereafter
mr chairman the vote would then be 11
yay
7a
by votes of 11 years and seven nays the
motion to adopt amendment two zero
2021-13578
it's passed
point of order representative calling
you recognized for point warner
who are the members whose votes were
just stripped from that tally
i wouldn't use the word script i don't
think any members votes were stripped
so i think you're asking which members
votes are not because they're not in
their seat when the matter was put to
question which i give that warning so
often
and i even paused letting them go but we
have a lot to do today
and trying to keep it moving here
i respect that but that was never
clarified we had a vote count that was
different
from the result that was given so that's
the number i'm after right now
well the rule is and we've we've gone
through this before
you have to actually i can tell you that
the members that
i actually have the court read it off
but right now
even if the member is appears in their
seat even though they're not in their
seat when the
matter is put to question the name of
the member is still
called so that was the we had that
incident before we remember it was not
in their seat that time the camera was
on
it was just an empty chair on the video
and they came in the middle of the vote
but in that in that case there was some
instant issue because that member's name
was not called this time the members
names would still be called so they're
not being stripped which is
that's how the rule was explained to me
by the clerk and that's the rule that's
followed in every committee
if the if the clerk can you read the
names of the members that were not
i do not have any cameras on yes thank
you mr chairman
representative ray newman representative
klein knight and
representative bolden
my understanding is i was so to call the
name so that that is what i did
i i understand that to be the correct
procedure
representative gatherer you're right mr
chairman
may i ask the question of the chair well
there's a point of order in that sense
supersede uh everything so
representative newman is the point of
ordering which to be recognized for
line of order when you said the word
mention my my camera was on
invisible at least on my computer and i
was representative wallace's name one of
the persons is that
correct or incorrect i didn't get the
three of them so
representative wallace's camera may or
may not be on from time to time
it was not nate red but represented
walls is physically in the room
and i can see him physically in his
chair when the matter is put to question
if you are physically in the room you
have to be in your chair that's the
why we it's important that members stay
in
something we talked about in this room
representative green you can relate to
this
some people want me he just eats around
and the reason why people
have to be in your assigned seat when
the matter is put to question
this is something we've gone over that's
what was said
that is the ruling of the chair if and
that's it i've made my ruling
from what is visible in the room i
recommend
that we're in the executive session
forever to leave their cameras on so
there's no misunderstanding
and that is it and that's the ruling of
the chair and i've
made the ruling i think i made it twice
now
so as you can tell i'm unlikely to
change my mind so i'm only going to
recognize
never to discuss whether the motion on
the floor i'm
going to recognize the representative
testament to make the most about the
pass
as amended make a motion out to pass
as amended for senate bill 40. and that
that motion has been seconded by
representative walls if a member wishes
to speak
about motion on the floor on excuse me
that's presented right now a lot the
past has amended who sucked it
representative wallace oh sorry thank
you that member will be recognized
representative true you're recognized a
lot of information mr question
[Music]
of the vote on the amendment if i recall
correctly it was a vote by 11
to 7 in support of adopting the event
eleven years seven days
representative uh harriet gaffrey you
were recognized
um i just want you to know that i do
object to it okay
um i i really feel as though um
we're kind of like we're going overboard
mr chair we really are
it's rule 107 of house rules and
i emphasize that i don't have much
discretion with that
uh that's what the rule is if i didn't
enforce it it made
exceptions i don't think that would
serve as well i really wish
and i understand that people object at
this point
[Music]
it passed by 11 years so if you count
those three votes anyway
it's not going to change the outcome but
i really think this is formal
substance at this point i'm only
recognizing people to speak
on the motion of octopasis amendment all
right
the chairs made that ruling i'm not
going to change my role i'm not going to
overwhelm myself i've made it
that's it so i wish we could move on
with what i would say
a bill that we well hb45 we could not be
passed on consent
and i really hope that we pass senate
bill for your consent with or without
said amendments
representative panthelockus you're
recognized i just want to
say i'm gonna vote for the bill but i
think we need
to understand that everyone
in that room has to be in their seat
so it should be that they have to have
the cameras
and i hope we stop this damn argument
as well representative pandermakis i'm
on your side with that
and uh i won't just say just for
clarification that not every member in
the room has a computer
i don't believe so that's part of the
just i'm just saying that for just the
people at home understand that but
you have to be in your seat when you
take a vote
or it does not count right in that room
who beat mr death correct i i
agree 100
representative klein knight you're
recognized
so i'm allowed to vote on this because
my camera's on the overall bill but even
though i wasn't allowed to vote on the
amendment even though when you said
three people don't have their cameras on
i immediately turned it on that wasn't
a notice to turn my camera on i'm very
confused
because i immediately turned my camera
on and i have enough i have a follow-up
question before you meet me
if we go back to youtube and it shows
that my camera was on time of vote are
you going are we going to be
like update anything or like if i have
evidence
that shows my camera was on
let me explain the rules of tier at this
moment in time that's that would take
about 10 minutes
but i think in what okay then just
keep going i think from what you said
though you admitted that your camera
wasn't on
when the matter was put to question so i
think it's pretty clear in the rules
and i mean i will say i did explain it
before we start
so i'm going to move i'm going to do at
this point
i'm going to move the question the
matter is now will be put to question
the motion is ought to pass as amended
point of order we're in the voting mode
if you are not in support mr chairman
i'd like to make a point of order
we're
mr chairman you stated earlier that a
point of order supersedes everything
else
you're not recognized to speak at this
time and you're out of order
you're in the voting mode the matter has
been already been put to question
now if you were in support of the motion
about the past as amended
we say yay if you were opposed please
say name
the clerk will now call the role vice
chairman welch
yes representative burke
yes representative hopper
no representative green
yes representative wallace
yes representative testerman
yes representative true
yay representative pratt
yes representative marston
sitting in my chair yes
[Music]
the clerk votes yes representative
harriet gathering
no representative pantalakis
yes representative sue newman
no representative borden a
yes representative muse
yes oh representative ray newman
yes representative bowden
yes
representative connolly yes
representative klein knight yes
representative bradley yes
chairman chair votes yes
mr chair the ver the vote is 18 yay
three nay i my vote of 18 days in three
names
about the pass as amended has passed
i'll put down consent is there any
objection
no representative ray newman are you
objecting to
senate bill 40 going on the consent
calendar
no i am not at this time we will now
close the executive session on senate
bill 40.
representative bourdain the um you have
for senate bill 122 has now
been distributed excuse me we have not
been distributed in the room but we do
have
a copy of it uh what we'll do is we're
not going to go into recess but i'm
going to pass it out
but i will be recognizing you
representative once we open the year do
you need a majority opinion
will it be a majority report for senate
bill 40
representative testament
yes
to indicate i my hand is raised and that
probably is why you asked me if i was
opposed but
appropriately that's what we're supposed
to do is put our hand up in
in the computer if we are remote is that
correct
it is easier for me to realize that
someone has a hand raised when they
put a little digital hand up this little
blue square
top left of your screen but
at the same time if you're just waving
at the screen i
don't always know if you're waving what
you're doing and i might miss it
and it's also easier
[Music]
and could i have a follow-up mr chairman
did you say yes representative raymond
when you're recognized
thank you um one of the problems out
here and
this is really intended to lower the the
temperature to
to reduce the arguments is that my
confusion
earlier was the fact that there are
people in the room who
are have they're represented
from our perspective as being remote
that they are remote so number one could
you tell us
who on the people
that are remote in on
your side i think all of the democrats
are remote today
representative located in the room
uh okay thank you and when we did the
role
start the meeting when i as we do i have
a they call it the chairman's script i
read all these similar piece of paper
it's probably the same script every time
when people answer they are present they
say
present in the room so that's the only
times ready
to disclose who is present in the room
and who's not
if you are present in the room and this
has been the practice of releasing this
committee
the entire time i can physically see
that you're in
sitting in your seat yeah and you have a
device
whether you're in the room you don't
need to have the camera so i can see the
person in their seat
and that's the best clarification of how
we're going forward
so thank you mr chair i agree
with the previous rule it was just
confusing out here and not knowing how
to
pay mark let me take uh you could repeat
it
so but this time i'm going to open the
executive sessions
open the executive session on senate
bill 122.
i did
the chair will recognize representative
john
representative bourne to make motion
about the past and offered amendment
thank you mr chair i do offer a motion
to office with an amendment
2021-1308
h
and is there a second in that motion so
again
that motion has been segmented by
representative welsh
representative boarding you wish to
speak to the
amendment and that just to clarify
that's amendment number 2021-1308
h yes mr chairman thank you
um we have basically taken
most of what is in the original
122 as passed by the senate
uh removed uh section uh that has to do
with h.b
123 which passed in the senate
uh removed the section that has to do
with
increased penalties for therapy uh
dogs and
i think that's it but
we basi have included uh the
section on uh
immunity to uh punishment for recording
uh um
medical needs for uh during a pr
by a prostitute
included the area for
including great grandparents as
part of the guardianship path
and uh included the uh i'll counsel
on um
or autism uh this spectrum disorder
represents the chair inquires of a
question
he passed a similar house bill uh
offered certain types of immunity
for uh situation human trafficking
is your amendment is it are we passing a
repetitive provision
my understanding is are you referring to
hb uh
uh 93 123.
uh that that section was removed from
122.
that was my way of asking tell me the
hospital number but thank you
so just to clarify what
123 which we passed
in that according to the docket
and this is just what the docket says is
on the consent
calendar in the center so
it looks like that will find his way at
least to
in all likelihood find its way to the
[Music]
governor's desk
so just
provide that information representative
tesla you recognize
yeah so i'm confused here i
this 122 was an omnibus
monster and
this amendment
if you take the six things that are
here make sure i understand this correct
i've been
checking it but it it left the human
trafficking thing
uh and it left the grandparents thing
is that is that true
yes representative boarding may i
recognize you to respond to
uh representative kessler's question
uh thank you uh one second i want to
verify it before i continue
um
yes so we have left in the section
the part has to do with human
trafficking
uh the grandparents our great
grandparents
and the council for autism
disorder
thank you and representative boarding i
may inquire
but is this the only amendment that you
have prepared
yes it is
representative part you're recognized
for a question
when we take the vote mr chairman is it
going to be
ought to pass as amended or we're doing
the amendment and then not to pass
the message it's whether to adopt the
amendment okay that's the that's right
now so
all right and then the author pass
as amendments so
and if i may ask a question of um
do you recognize ask a question me or to
representative board all right
so as i'm looking at senate bill 122.
we left in section two three
and a half of five is that correct
that's correct and then so it replaces
the rest of the bill
yes thank you it looks like it did more
striking than okay
so it's i don't know this is an official
term it's less of anonymous
so i suppose
i will say that it would be very if we
don't pass the amendment
i i don't like the idea of passing the
bill
simply because of hp 123 which i want i
think
that was on consent i think he was 19 to
2 in the room
but we recommend here i would hope that
way to try this again seeing no further
hands raised
the mat
representative newman hey
i ask a question of the chair
i prefer to move the question is it
about the underlying bill
it's about procedure and voting and it
would help me
as we're about to vote so i'd like to be
able to ask my question about the
procedure
well so i'm gonna move the question and
then we can
i s i i witness you cast most of this
committee for the entire
term so i i think we'll be able to make
it through this one we'll just move the
questions
but we see you know from the hands mr
speaker
i'd like to make a point of order
the question is whether to adopt
amendment two zero
two one dash one three zero h
if you would support him adopting the
amendment please say yay if you're
opposed you say nay
the clerk will not call
chairman welch yes
representative bert yes
representative hopper yes
representative green yes
representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative
representative pratt hey
i'm sorry no
representative marston no
and i'm sitting in my chair the clerk
votes yes
representative harry gathering yes
representative panzolakis yes
representative o'hearn i'm sorry
representative sue newman
what yes
representative borden a yes
representative muse yes
representative ray newman
yes representative bolden
yes representative conley
yes representative klein knight
yes representative bradley
yes chairman
the chair votes yes mr chairman the vote
is
18 yay 3 nay
[Music]
amendment 2021-1308h
passed uh representative boarding we
should be
recognized as a motion of from odd to
pass as amended
thank you mr chair i do uh make that
[Music]
turn your camera on
i'll show you that that motion has been
seconded by representative welch
seeing no uh hands raised
i was important you wish to discuss your
motion i will
allow you to do that but i don't see any
hands raised
uh representative roberts you're
recognized
mr chairman i'm sorry could you please
please tell me who made the motion and
who seconded the motion for ought to
pass with amendment
uh uh the motion of obama passes
amendment was made by
representative gordnay and that it was
seconded by representative
welch thank you
okay so
vice chairman welch all right
before you i i don't i have to actually
i think i can move the question
oh i'm sorry matt the matter will now be
uh put the question
uh if you can support him on the rocket
passes amended please say
yay if you are opposed please say nay uh
clerk
vice chairman welch don't change my mind
yes
representative bert no
representative popper
representative greene
no representative wallace
yes representative testerman
yes representative true
nay representative pratt
oh representative marston
no the clerk votes yes
representative harriet gathright yes
representative panzolakis yes
representative sue newman yes
representative borden a yes
representative muse yes
representative ray newman
hello representative ray newman
yes yes
representative bolden yes
representative conley yes
representative klein knight yes
representative bradley yes
chairman chair votes yes
mr chairman the vote is 15 yay nay
all right voted fifteen a is in six days
the motion of occupants is amended at
the task
representative board name will you be
preparing a majority report
yes here i will send that to you this
afternoon
would it be a minority report
that is true but
but if you have to be known by knowing
report
this time we're going to close the
executive session
on senate bill
122.
before we move on to anything else
there's a few house bills that we have
that have passed but the senate has made
some
amendments to it and my understanding is
that
as the house we can either concur
or we can object so
one of those is uh
house bill
and that's going to do
by the chief of police in the in the
county sheriff's order
we forgot to put the word sheriffs in
there is all what the senate did
i i didn't i understood when they said
police officers or police department
including the county sheriffs
uh whether i am right or wrong with that
all the
senate amendment did was include
sheriffs in that so
if this passed i believe some consent
that this doesn't change this actually
improves the intent of the bill
does anyone on this committee have any
objection with allowing the sheriffs to
enjoy the same luxury as the
state and local police officers when it
comes to destroying valueless part of it
i have no problem i can't i didn't think
there would be a problem but
we never never know
so i i would encourage us to concur with
the senate on that
amendment the house bill who's on the
driver
so
another one is
bill 239 relative to the prosecution of
certain assaults against minus
another film that was passed
in the house and i'll tell you right now
what that role was
what they did was it what the bill had
done it was
extending the stature limitation of six
years within the victim's 18th birthday
the senate did not agree with the six
years they made an amendment to
three years and if anyone has any
comments on that i i like the six years
i certainly wouldn't want to see the
bill
disappear because it's only three years
three is better than
it's still an improvement to the
existing walk i don't have the
rationale for the center why they did
not like the six years
representative ray newman you're
recognized
yes mr chair thank you i have a
parliamentary the
the senate changed something in a house
bill and the house bill comes back
i thought that came back to the full
house and not to the committee
is that incorrect no you are correct
okay you asked the question i was just
wondering what we're doing here
we're having we're having a very casual
discussion and the reason why is i like
to think that
because this bill came out of our
committee that we're all familiar with
and there's been some minor changes to
some of the provisions
and yes but it goes to the full house
but
i've been it's been recommended that you
discuss it with the committee
and that's what i'm doing allowing
everyone to voice their opinions on what
the senate has done with their
amendments to house bills that we passed
we obviously didn't pass that language
we didn't find that language necessary
but at the same time
i value everyone's opinion so
i i would i would appreciate everyone's
input with interesting representatives
as i'm trying to recognize the chair i
remember the bill
at my age that's a good thing
[Music]
and it was something about the 18
the up to the age of 18 was something in
our bill
our bill extended
to six years past 18 was was that our
bill
so the house bill version of the bill
sets the status limitations for first
and second
degree assault against buyers that's six
years from the victim's 18th birthday
so while the victim is a minor the
statute of limitations does not begin
to run so once they turn 18 it begins to
run
the house bill would have made that a
six year national invitation now i
obviously had no problem with that but
the senate bill did
it limits it to three years from the
victim's
18th birthday representative
true you recognized thank you and
without knowing the reasons behind
the senate change um
i would certainly think that would be
good when you go to a conference
i agree i like i personally i like the
six years better
i mean i think an 18 year old to the
point that 21 i mean
we're telling risk we passed laws and
that person came to buy cigarettes
so i i'm just looking at you know
talking about the maturity of the human
brain we've heard tests on all these
bills about all this stuff
and this is someone who's been a victim
of a violent crime who's a minor
i don't see the harm making it six years
instead of three
representative green you're recognized
thank you uh what was the vote of the
senate on that
from the amendment yes
why look that up representative bourdain
you're recognized
thank you mr chair uh i can't agree with
this
change i prefer that if we
do anything we have a committee of
conference
and see if we can get the senate to come
to
uh agreement mr chairman it was 24
yes zero no
[Music]
it's going
oh representative uh please you're
recognized
so i just just wanted to remind members
of the committee that
we've had other bills that we've
actually
itl because we increased the statute of
limitations so long
that it created real doubts around
whether or not people
could be prosecuted whether witnesses
could be found whether
evidence would still uh uh
would actually still be viable um
you know to me uh six years seems to be
a pretty reasonable measure given
especially given the fact where we are
now
um and uh i agree with representative
bordenay
i'm not inclined to agree to this change
i i thank you representative i love it
but i love the unity on this one so
all right representative brandon when
you recognize
thank you mr chair since i was only
asking a question before i
give you my opinion on this i agree they
should go to six years thank you
all right what we're going to do now is
that we're going to it is
10 42 we are going to be uh in recess
to at least 11
11 45 so for one hour what
11 30. if you're running your run late
but yes
yeah someone hash things out quick
we'll be at recess to 11 45.
where do we go
can you guys hear me
can you hear me uh yes we can
okay yes i text daryl he said 10 minutes
he said soon
so i said 5 10 and he typed 10.
just so you know so we're waiting for
them okay
i don't think that's fair to the
feared to us i agree 100 yeah
i agree 100 because he he should have
just
texted and said we're going to be out
another 15 minutes or so
agreed i want everybody to remember this
is
being recorded i'm okay with that we're
not saying
actually this is the perfect time for us
to have public statements right now
they left the room they left it
recording the public has total access to
what we're saying
and i can go on the record saying i've
been muted
multiple occasions where it should be
fair and open discussions and even when
you don't agree with somebody
i don't think that should be a
discussion that we should be having
right now second session is meant an
extra section right now we're in a break
well if i'm muted during executive
session
i can't do my my job that i was voted
into office to represent a bunch of
people
to have that voice so i mean now is a
good time to have a platform as any
i agree this is not the appropriate
platform
hmm
foreign
[Music]
it's now 20 minutes past our recess
does anybody know when we're gonna start
no this is ridiculous
we are now 30 minutes past recess
what happens if we don't get any
direction do we just wait here
until the chair shows up
yeah yep yep that's what we do
it looks like they're coming back in um
it looks like he's coming back in but i
saw all of them go
over to burke i saw david go over the
bird i saw
um green go over to burke so i had to
think it has to do with that
141. ridiculous this is the chicken
bill taking it out of the state i just i
had a doctor's appointment because of
this
yesterday
yes
since
good to go
at this time we're going to open the
executive session on senate bill
141.
would you like to recognize the member
to make that motion of
exp to legislative
um what which one senate bill 141.
does any member wish to be recognized to
make a motion
of nxp in the legislature
representative testament you're
recognized
to make a motion to
the
[Music]
that motion to let's say has been
seconded by representative pantologist
[Music]
i want to guess who's playing music
all right does anyone wish to speak to
i'll just open it for discussion
i don't want to speak at this time
please raise your hand
representative hopper you were
recognized uh thank you mr chairman
i'll be voting against the motion of the
expedition legislature
for a few reasons one it was clear
during the testimony that the
state deadline seem to uh be
[Music]
getting their act together only because
this bill was introduced
which leads me to believe that once this
bill is uh
disposed of they couldn't go right back
to what what they were doing
it has also been brought to my attention
that uh with new
software they're using the new gun line
it will
amount to a de facto gun registration
for everybody that buys a handgun
in the state of new hampshire for these
and other reasons i
i am going to vote against the motion
thank you representative and delocation
recognized
thank you mr chairman i believe this
bill will put a burden
on the taxpayers and i believe the state
police
because it's been one little error but
it was
it's done a good job since i've been in
legislation
thank you
representative walsh you recognize yes
i'm going to vote in favor of icl
because currently state law prohibits
firearm sales to individuals under an
ex-pate
domestic violence protective order
[Music]
that does a lot for the folks who need a
protective order
the feds don't get that they don't have
access to that
so i think this
the gun line protects women in those
circumstances
and it's mostly women who get their
protective voters
representative you're recognized thank
you mr chairman
i am opposed to the itl a yes vote on a
motion
to itl is a vote in favor of a wait
period
for gun buyers this is an anti-gun vote
we had a tremendous amount of testimony
from the gun organizations
of gun groups store owners
that were overwhelmingly in the public
that were overwhelmingly
in favor of senate bill 141. senate bill
will solve a problem that has festered
for decades so this is not
something new
i believe it was since 1999
that the gun line was established could
have been 98 but i believe 99.
they have been okay
at times in other times they've been
terrible
i talked to a few people that waited
four weeks to eight weeks to get
approved to buy
a handgun in new hampshire and this was
only about eight months ago
have they improved it yes but there's
still
a wait period
i am against a wait period
what they're doing now the state police
is if the gun store calls them
they don't answer their phone this is
what the gun stores are telling
me they're not answering for one to
three hours
then they'll answer the phone you know
because they're next in line so they'll
answer the phone
and then what happens is they will do
the background
within four to ten minutes
all right but you had to wait three
hours or one hour to get there
on the denial part it is easy
to fix the denial part
if you're denied for a wrong name in
another state or even in the same state
or a date of birth is an issue or
something whatever the reason is
you go on their website and you don't
have to hire an attorney
i've talked to people that have done
this for something small
and they've gone on there and they have
fixed it within the
time allotted the biggest thing that i
want to make sure everybody understands
a long gun a rifle
the store calls nicks
directly it's approved or it's
disapproved
a handgun the store calls the state
police
the state police by law federal
law they have no choice about it they
have to call next now when i say
call it's through a computer so you know
i'm 60 years old that's what i'm using
is called
but they do it through the computer they
type it up get it out
and they get a denial or they get an
acceptance
the new hampshire state police has to
follow what they say
now what the state police also does for
handguns only
so if you want to buy a rifle you're
going to get it in four to six minutes
tops
a handgun what the state police will
also do is if they
question the name and say okay he got
accepted from the feds
so technically they could call the gun
store back and say yes the guys accept
it
but they don't in some cases
they'll start looking at the local
courts they will
uh fax the old paper way
their local police and say hey we're
just wondering
how is this done that's
a further weight it's not by law
it's not my statute they're running
rogue over there
they do as they want and they're not
following the law the law says abc
will disqualify you or abc won't
disqualify you
they're going beyond that and they don't
need to do that
that's why passing or voting against
this itl and supporting another motion
that i would make
um is the right thing to do because
bottom line
this is an anti-gun bill what this is is
it is a vote
to support a wait period if this bill
goes down
that's all this bill does is to keep
the new hampshire state police in line
with doing what they're doing
which is causing new hampshire citizens
to have a wait period
to purchase their handguns from
a ffl licensed dealer in new hampshire
now the other thing too real quick is
i was told uh by several gun stores
when they had this long wait of the four
to
you know eight weeks and there was only
a handful of people
that had to wait six months just a
handful
but six months can you imagine that if
you wanted a gun you had to wait six
months
but most of it was four to eight weeks
and this went on for months
at shooter's outpost he told me
personally when i visited
that he had two over 2
000 guns that were sold
sitting in the back room waited
the four to eight weeks to get a
background check done
through new hampshire or through new
hampshire state police
that if he called nicks directly like a
rifle
because some people bought a handgun and
a rifle the same time
they walked out with the rifle they had
to sit and wait and wait and wait
so can you imagine a small store
with just 10 guns that's all they got
10 guns sitting in the back i don't know
what that price would be
five eight thousand dollars that they're
waiting on just sitting there
that the store can't take that money and
pay their employees in the light bill
and everything
else so they're stuck this
is wrong it's anti-business and it's
waiting for a yeah it's supporting a
wait period so i hope you vote
no like i'm going to because this is a
wait period
if it's good enough for the rifles to go
to knicks straight
in the three states around us because a
lot of times we've talked
oh we gotta be just like massachusetts
vermont new york
maine well if we join all them
a hundred percent of their guns go to
next and it's a system that works
matter of fact my old state uh
apparently i didn't buy any guns because
it was short-lived during that period of
time
i i was told in early 90s they did go
through the new you know their own
system like we have
and it was costly they said why are we
doing this it's a federal mandate
it's real quick just to go through the
feds
we allow rifles like new hampshire does
yeah why don't we allow them to do the
pistols too
so that's what they're doing so the
three states around us are doing that
so again this is a wait period motion
so if you support a wait period for gun
buyers in new hampshire
then support the itl and i'm not because
i don't support a wait period for the
gun buyers and i definitely support gun
stores to not have to hold a gun
for four to eight weeks while they're
sitting on that money
can't you know support their store thank
you mr chairman and i
hope everybody does not support the itl
[Music]
representative klein now you're
recognized
thank you chair i'm going to be
supporting the itl because
i care more about people's lives than
gun owners businesses
chair now recognizes representative
tesla
i agree with uh representative byrd
when he talks about you know we don't
need
a wait period uh for the uh
people first seeing a firearm but
i picked up and i don't know what the
issue is the shooter's outpost
because they're a big big business they
they do an awful lot of cases
but i have a friend who called me uh
with and sent me statistics on
the uh the delay or delays or
how long it takes he keeps a spreadsheet
of every phone call he's made he works
friday saturday sunday at a gun store
in amherst and uh
he has no cases of uh
having to dial numerous times after
eight
after early april after early april he
his business as usual they're five i
think about his 5.8 seconds or something
like that
from the time he calls until he's got an
answer
go ahead and sell the gun or don't
celebrate
prior to that he will admit you know he
was
put online they weren't answering and so
on you know
in march and early april but after that
it's been cleaned up now so i
i'm believing that they can do it
granted they know we're looking at them
i have some difficulty with
some of the gun groups who support this
now and didn't support it later
i also have some difficulty with i mean
i am
wavering but i'm going to vote itl
because we have a company like microsoft
we just signed a contract with
with the uh the guideline to keep the
data
on the people so that said
let's go
see no further hands raised the matter
went out
now be put to question
if you support the motion of any speed
legislation
please say a you opposed dc
department i'll call the role vice
chairman welch
hi representative bert
no
representative hopper no
representative green yes
representative wallace yes
representative testerman yes
representative true
i'm sorry
representative pratt
representative marston yes
the clerk votes no representative
harriet gathering
yes representative panzalakis
yes representative sue newman
yes representative bordenay
yes representative muse
yes representative ray newman
yes bolden
yes representative conley
yes representative klein knight
yes representative bradley
yes chairman
mr chairman the vote is 15 yay 6a
has passed will be a majority report
written by
[Music]
the writer majority
representative i can imagine you'll be
drafting i'm waiting on your other
reforms
all right yes it will be a
beautiful uh minority report sure well
this time we're going to close the
executive session on senate bill
[Music]
141.
we have a list of retaining bills here
and there's going to be subcommittees
inside
go through that process right now
if anyone wishes to volunteer for the
subcommittee it's probably a good idea
to raise your hand
so hb205 relative to incarceration under
suspended sentence we retained that bill
representative conley i believe you had
an amendment for that bill
so that bill the amended amendment that
you have is actually part of senate bill
96 which is not in our committee to the
house judiciary committee
so although we'll appoint a
sub-committee for this it may be all for
nothing
but just keep let's monitor what happens
with
senate bill 96.
anyone we wish to volunteer to be on the
subcommittee
i'll volunteer chair
thank you representative and you have
been so appointed to the subcommittee
of the hb 205
you will be joined by representative
pantologist
can i can i ask a question in a chair
okay you wish to be on the sub community
no no no i just want to know how many
people supposed to be
on the committee from what i understand
it's discretionary
this one this this in all honesty this
building
when we retained it we actually had not
left our committee we would have been
reconsidered and passed it i believe the
amendment that representative conley had
was something that was
favorable by the majority of women
favored by the majority committee
i'm a co-sponsor daniel i just think
that
it's in senate bill 96 i don't know
what's going to happen to that but
i believe the amendment whatever
something we have i think representative
paulie did all the work we need to do
it just which i thank you for doing
it just we we can't do much on it but
i'm just going to point
up to me so let's be people to monitor
what's going on
but i'm not sure there's something we
even have to meet it might
it might work itself out and if
everyone's happy with representative
colony's
uh proposed amendment
then it's all for nothing so
representative she wished to be on this
on the subcommittee with the chair
yes all right that makes five
perfect so who who are the five people
klein knight
was in a pantologist
representative conley representative
welch
and myself
okay
so this is i mean so in regards to the
relevant of legalization and regulation
of cannabis and making
appropriations there are therefore
that subcommittee will be the same
subcommittee
for relative the home cultivation of
cannabis
plants uh in the possession of certain
certain cannabis infused products
although the employments will be made
separately
it's my intent for those to all be heard
together about the same committee
and really if we're going to put
something out there should really just
be one bill
hopefully capturing positives of
or whatever whatever you guys want to do
with it
numbers so now hp 629
esp 237
and i think we can also put um hp 526.
i'd like to be on the committee i don't
want to be the chair i'd like to be on
the committee
representative ross do you wish to be on
that subcommittee
yes
[Music]
representative connolly do you wish to
be on that something do you want the
prime sponsor of 237
yes mr chairman i would
[Music]
i did promise representative true he
could be on i believe representative are
you the pr
you are a sponsor of the 629
i can't i think i sponsored co-sponsored
one you correspond to 6 29's
representation you wish to be on that's
okay
thank you
[Music]
in the interest of uh keeping a healthy
bipartisan is there
someone from the other caucus that
wished representative dwight was your
hand is raised
yes i i would go on but i want to know
how many bills you're combining
three three what what
motivation what has to do with
recreational and commercialization
you want us to do with penalties i don't
want anything to do with cannabis
you would be upset
[Music]
you wish to be appointed your name is
amazed
woman doesn't take this long
i can't hear you
you're muted ray i'm trying to get back
to my video
uh i have just one question before i
commit to this how many more
um bill how many more sub committees are
there going to be
yeah how many of you pointing right now
can you tell us that
i don't want to have to raise my hand
for all of them
is it difficult
[Music]
i'm just not going to answer that
question i mean it's difficult in your
hand
i'm just going thank you mr chairman
he'll be glad to be on that committee
representative newman you are now
disappointed
i'll be bringing myself tonight to me as
well
just so anyone knows when you have these
subcommittees just because you're not
appointed as a member of something does
not mean you cannot participate
or attend the meetings all right
everyone is welcome to
partake when it becomes the subcommittee
making the committee recommendation
[Music]
uh they wouldn't have any uh vote on
that
mr chair who's who's chairing that
committee
do you think i would make a great share
of that committee you okay
[Music]
that appointment by the way is 237 629
and 526
you understand that yes
did you repeat that one more time 526
and 237 29. thank you
the next one is bill
238 prohibiting
uh uh
being provoked based on a victim's
actual or perceived gender gender
identity gender expression or sexual
orientation
from being used as a defense in
manslaughter
represent bradley you wish to be
appointed
members in the room wish to partake
completely i'd like to
chair
yes you can if you choose not to attend
i can't control that and we've been
appointed
all right i won't i won't be attending
that's nice
it's good i appreciate taking the series
representative
[Music]
you wish yes thank you
mr chair i would also like to be on that
committee
[Music]
representative hopper sure thank you
representative papa would you do the
honors of cheering that's up minnie
thank you thank you very much
participate so i would not
it's because you're not officially a
point doesn't mean you can't be involved
in years
hp 230 uh excuse me hb 253 requires law
enforcement officers to use body-worn
cameras an establishing grant program
to assist local law enforcement agencies
to purchase body-worn cameras
just before we made appointments there
uh we did pass
in hp2 a provision that would
somewhat cover that also hb96 i'm sorry
senate bill 96 which is in us
judiciary committee also covers
at least the intent of what this bill is
so i i would recommend
anyone on the subcommittee to keep an
eye on how those
will
you are a sponsor of hp 253 is that
correct
hp 253 yes um i have to look it up
no i don't have all the bills that
because sponsored memorized i'm sorry
what's the number again 253
i am not a co-sponsor um you're not
253 is conley manchapudi wilhelm cushing
the branch lauren
are the sponsor representative conley
there you have it
you've been so appointed
president did you wish to be appointed
as well
you've been so appointed
[Music]
you've been so appointed okay
representative pratt
um
you have a question no you want me to
or unless you want to take it that's why
representative green and representative
proud have been appointed
i know you didn't have time for the
subcommittee so i was hesitant to point
you to another one
that yeah no i i could yeah
so i just figured i wouldn't point
anyone all right perfect
sounds good to me
what's that sp hp hp
we know in hp 408 that's relative to
employment restrictions for registered
sex offenders
[Music]
yes i would like to be appointed to
hb408
and for your volunteering i will appoint
you as the chair of that so community
representative harvard sure
you get appointed
i just like hanging out with
representative rose actually
mr chairman mike represent popular
movement
no i just want to make it clear i've
never been the chairman of any committee
like this i'm not sure if i would be
better off to be there as a member
my understanding is that representative
harper at one point was a chair of a
committee
and i'm sure he would provide wisdom and
guidance to make sure that
you you are okay all right
if he doesn't please let me know
representative jordan representative i
don't believe you if you've been
appointed attending representative
[Music]
you did all right i uh i will not be
appointed to this committee you would
you would like to or not i would like to
not love your honesty
i miss you representative board
well representative i i looks for like
it i don't look like no one in your
coffee wants to be applying to the
subcommittee so i'm going to have to
unfortunately make some appointments so
i don't mind
i can be on that subcommittee
thank you representative bradley
the representative bradley given the
concerns that i had about this bill i
would be willing to serve as well
thank you very much
and uh representative i'm gonna point
you to this one uh as well
mr mr chair all right
we also recognize representative ray
newman thank you
how big is this committee going to be
i'm only making them five
okay thank you so hb
576 that was the bill that we retained
and then reconsidered and passed on
consent
only to find out by the third that we
could not have reconsidered the bill
at least that was procedurally improper
despite that being a tremendous show of
unity amongst the committee
i just don't feel i feel that we would
pass this bill
so when i say that we we can probably
get away without appointing a
subcommittee for this one
we can what i will do just to make sure
we don't forget about it in case we're
all busy i'm just going to have a
three-person subcommittee be appointed
of myself
our representative welsh and
representative harry cavalry just to
make sure that we don't forget about the
bill
make sure he moves along but it would
have
passed our consent out of this committee
had there not been a procedural wonder
by us collectively does that sound good
but don't be this don't be discouraged
[Laughter]
i'll be the chair of that committee
so hb 579
[Music]
is requiring notice to the public before
immigration checkpoints conducted
we recall that that was the bill we
heard testimony from an american citizen
for some reason kept getting seized at a
immigration checkpoint
around lincoln three times um
sponsored the bill had some personal
issues and he was obviously family
issues
we have the blessing to retain that bill
it will require some work to be done on
it because the
notice requirement in the bill is
married after the drug driving laws
uh the notice for a drunk driving
checkpoint which
wouldn't work if we're not once
defensively doing that checkpoint
in this case we would have to provide a
notice we're gonna anticipate
so just keep that in mind
would there be anyone who is to be
appointed to said subcommittee
representative wallace you have been so
appointed
yes i'd like to be in that committee
[Music]
well i'm trying to share the wealth i
don't believe i've appointed you to a
subcommittee
i've been on a committee earlier in the
year with
uh representative guthrie
that's true that is true you remind me
something when you're right
but that is just one something most
people can have more than one
with the exception of her well we'll put
representative
on this one and i know you're busy but
we'll put representative burt on this
bill as well
what's the number 579
but representative martin you're correct
you are already appointed or something
[Music]
that's a good one for me i i'm just
asking the representative
right is there a member of your
conference that when you wish to
volunteer on their behalf
don't you already have five on there
isn't it i
have representative wallace
representative knight representative
burton representative welsh
i thought you said march then i did make
the appointment of representative
marston
under the belief that he has not been
appointed to a subcommittee yet
he also graciously corrected me and it
is correct
he is actually on a subcommittee already
all right who's that anthologist your
hand is raised
yes i'll i'll go on it
thank you
mr chairman i have a question
i have a question about that though
is that something that they
can do when it's federal
so putting them in the spark
so we have no control over what the
federal officers do
if they want to set up an immigration
checkpoint we can't stop that
now what happens is if if local law
enforcement
wishes to participate in that
there needs to be local laws that need
to be
complied with what's happening is
apparently and we heard testimony about
this
that i found very concerning that an
american citizen he wasn't born here but
he is a
just as much of a citizen as anyone else
as an american citizen
it keeps getting detained at these
checkpoints which is unfortunate
and what this would do bill's trying to
make sure the notice would be publicized
[Music]
so the dilemma is that we are
publicizing a notice
for a federal officers doing an
immigration checkpoint
but that's because the state officials
want to participate
they notice that for a drunk driving
checkpoint you have to go into superior
court and get the court to approve the
notice
and then there's some other parts go
along with it i i didn't think that you
could not use the same
notice procedures that was my humble
opinion
i said you really didn't come up with an
enormous procedure but what i'm hearing
if the co-op
if that's how the checkpoints are being
operated and
you have american citizens being
detained at these
while they question american citizen
citizenship
i don't know thank you
a difficult problem to say the least
but we can't we can't stop the feds from
doing the checkpoint
we don't have to participate which is my
understanding constitution
thank you
representative wallace is the chair
hbo 598 relative to a portion of many
incentives to be served
to be out of control represent catholics
you she wished to be part of the sub
community 598
yes i do thank you
members of my own coffee so involved
here all once now
i'd like to be on that representative
you've been so appointed to 598
fine i just won't participate
very nice so i'm being upfront and
honest
well you are serving on the subcommittee
right now with representative gathering
and perhaps in the infinite wisdom of
scheduling
it may make it easier if these are
scheduled the same day so maybe you guys
can kind of do one here and then the
next
you can appoint me
representative welch
what's the charge matter of this one
this has to do with the minimum
um sorry
relative to a portion of a minimum
sentence to be served to be honorable
for full
okay it's the truth in sentencing
that um
the commissioner said that you would be
happy to work with us as well
with this one just so you don't
represent you've been so important as
well
relative to manslaughter the use of
deadly force and circumstance involving
the sale or use of a controlled drug
so that listen to that bill uh we heard
some very compelling testimony
and just what we think about was
the person was at someone else's house
they purchased the
controlled substance from that person
due to a reaction from state-controlled
substance
caused them to go violently there was a
particular medical term for
what caused that person to kind of lose
have temporary insanity well
the drug dealer apparently murdered
the murder of the person
in their own house and however under the
current castle
doctrine laws or whatever we have in our
state uh
that person is not charged something to
think about
i know when we think of that you think i
think of uh
you know one person that's clean hands
but that's that's what happened that's
what brought
that's what this bill was intended to do
as written
it from what i would recall it says if
you
sell someone to control psalms in the
overdose you can be charged by
manslaughter so
this building i would encourage movers
on the sub
console with representative vincent on
the direction they want this to go just
as a
point of clarification anyone wish to be
appointed in this subcommittee
remember if i don't get volunteers this
will be the whole committee
long so i'm not chair
representative green
what's the number 603 thank you
easy number to remember representatives
committee uh i really don't see the
point of the bill at all
there's a lot of that going around here
the appointments
i forgot about our good friend
representative
[Music]
he's not here well i'll put
representative heard on that
okay i'll leave it to you deliver the
news
all right
question mr chair yes will
there be a list put out of the
subcommittees and
yes okay thank you
representative tested
representative uh represent
representative
did you wish to be on the subcommittee
mr chairman can you remind me the bill
again i'm sorry i lost track
it was representative uh vincent's bill
and
he testified when you know he wasn't
president
he did have a police officer with him
and uh um unfortunately a
mother whose son was murdered um
i remember now i remember now and this
the the intent of what was far the way i
thought
was was not necessarily a line but it's
very worthy of a discussion at least i i
feel so
so you can add me i agree with rep
ordinary i don't know if it's fixable
but
it's a concept that's worth discussion
so yes i'm happy to serve
well it's going to take a lot of work
and uh
considering i'm on four of these if
there's someone else who's willing to do
that work i would be happy to see that
position
you have your hand raised
thank you um i just wanted to mention
that if there's any subcommittee that
you wanted to add me to you don't have
to ask me i'm
happy to help well representative
you're off the hook we will replace you
with representative boulder
uh just a reminder hb620 that was
requiring law enforcement agencies to
gather and analyze certain
uh demographic information uh
representative conley and representative
gaffney i believe it's representative
hopper marston and representative welch
we've already been appointed a
subcommittee
representative gavin you have been
appointed to the chair of that committee
representative chessman you will chair
the uh 603
[Music]
obtaining a 000 sentence this is hp
excuse me hb
632 banging life centers of imprisonment
without parole for a juvenile predictive
homicide
uh yes you can put me in
i'll be there oh wow
i'd like to be in there
from any room from any members of my
caucus to be in there
so this with this one particularly um
as written in new hampshire law we kind
of came to the conclusion
it's unconstitutional after the
amendment
we had a deadline that i wasn't sure we
would be able to vet that by
i will share that amendment with the
subcommittee i don't
i don't even care if i get credit for it
but what it what it needs to do is that
our cap i got capital murder
um rsa 630 does not have the provisions
in there regarding juvenile but we'll
talk about that after but
okay who else represent the welsh
what's that
thank you
[Music]
i don't i don't support the bill as
written either i i
think this should be circumstances where
juvenile would be entitled but it can't
be
it can't be mandatory the supreme court
will
matter
and now we're being chaired by
representative welsh
i want to remember
that is representative harry gatherer
senator bradley representative wilder
from the royal
center all right
mr chair can we go back to uh hb147
the very first one 147. is that the one
that you told me i was on
before um but we'll do that one right
now
thank you thank you representative
gabriel right that would be
added by this guy
and this should be applying to the hp
one 17 hp 147
so appointed
representative hopper you've been so
appointed as well what is it
it's hp 147 relevant to assault against
an elderly person
[Music]
getting close to it
being elderly i'm sure you'll be a very
positive contributor to
this i hope i am at 60. represent news
yes
representative boarding yes
anyone else i'm saying true
representation would you do the honors
of uh cheering that's up today
thank you i think i'm missing a name
representative to the youtubers
okay i think it was missing
[Music]
so the only bill that we have left in
committee please quickly run senator 92
uh what i'm going to do with that one is
uh like we're going to
not hold off on executing that today we
will be meeting again
on the 19th
what days are gone yeah
[Music]
um
thank you because there is no rush to
get here at nine
i will it's not heads unofficially knows
what plan to be there for 10 o'clock
if that's the only bill this should be
the only bill we have
every year
[Music]
if anyone has any amendments whether you
remember this committee or not
please don't take your time let's get
them put out there
any other questions confused
representative panchalakis
wii u 205
house bill
so two or five
i think we
we i think i progressed with a colony on
that
that's knight tommy welch
myself
oh you did it okay and
he uh and i think he put himself on
there as well
the um issue with that is that that
representative calling already had an
abandoned draft that
was my impression would have passed had
we voted on it
unfortunately he retained it and was out
in new orleans we couldn't get it back
but
the amended version passed in the senate
is part of 96
76 it's unfortunate that bill's not in
our committee so it's
you know but if it passes on his own so
be it but that's
all we have to do i mean i couldn't
imagine any changes to the amendment
[Music]
is that rocker couple questions can you
email everybody a list of
all the bills
and secondly supplementing work is that
going to be done
in person
[Music]
what time are we meeting
i don't have an official time
[Music]
um i have a question i'm only chairing
one right
i think
would you like to cheer more no i don't
want to that's why i'm asking
just 620 is that correct well the chair
of 620.
i was retained i gave you my word
that i would have pointed to share that
subcommittee so i made that
appointment way back when we retained it
without knowing
i feel like that was months ago
but i made sure you share that one to
keep me warm i know and
oh and i'm chair 598
598 i represent welch's chair
okay i just need to fix my notes thank
you
cheers i'm good
i think i captured it all thank you
thank you